a gente já tinha marcado esse
treinamento de liderança em uma empresa
no interior de são paulo com os três
quatro meses de antecedência
dois dias antes do treinamento
acontecerá cliente me liga
cauê temos um problema a diretora da
unidade quer participar do treinamento
junto com a equipe o que fazer
aí eu disse a ela que não tem problema
nenhum a diretora participar do
treinamento junto com os gestores não é
afinal de contas e dá aquela conotação
de que estamos todos juntos no mesmo
barco disse que seria um problema se a
diretora participasse do treinamento e
os gestores se sentirem intimidados pela
presença dela esse poderia ser um grande
furo no barco e aí ela virou o telefone
e fala uma coisa que eu nunca esqueci
ela falou assim eu e você não tem idéia
de quem é andréia
esse negócio de liderança pode ser
engraçado né porque ele é que a gente
nunca esquece eu mesmo tive uma vida que
nunca mais me esqueci a laura laura
tomas agora uma gerente de um resort uma
estação de esqui que eu trabalhei eu
nunca tinha viajado nunca tinha saído do
país o trajeto de avião e lá estava eu
de repente numa estação de esqui
curtindo aquele momento achando que esse
seria o cenário que haveria maior parte
do tempo né esse resort é tão chique era
tão elegante para vocês terem uma idéia
dá uma olhadinha no banheiro de um dos
quartos do resort
repara o porcelanato não é olha beleza
nos alemanha banheira central
o que me chama atenção também a limpeza
do lugar ficava assim depois que eu
limpava
eu era o camareiro do resort não é eu
era responsável pela faxina pela limpeza
pela arrumação dos quartos e laura era
gestor eu sempre conversava com a laura
falava assim laura um dia que você tiver
alguma coisa a mais para fazer um ir
além eu tô aqui eu queria aprender
o filme me formei hotelaria então fazia
sentido
aí um dia lá agora falou pra mim é assim
então eu seu pedido
é uma ordem temos um importante projeto
de segurança no trabalho e na nossa área
eu preciso de alguém criativo para
conduzirem sem você topa eu falei na
hora
claro que eu topo imagina uma coisa
importante né
e aí eu falei assim palavra como é que
vai ser meu dia-a-dia daqui pra frente
ela fala igual vai continuar limpando os
quartos e além disso cuida do projeto de
segurança
eu falei é exatamente o que eu pensei
que ia falar tudo bem mas de qualquer
forma fiquei animado e dia 14 de outro
limpando aqui e ali sempre com idéias
sobre segurança no trabalho um dia ela
me liga em uma empresa de limpeza e
outra fala qual é preciso que você me
represente uma reunião mas fique
tranquilo porque essa reunião vai ser
justamente sobre segurança no trabalho
você domina o assunto é claro agora para
pedir essa reunião para que eu possa me
preparara falou agora estou pronto fui
eu
e lá fui eu para essa reunião um lugar
que nunca tinha ido no resort uma sala
chique de reunião quando eu entro na
sala quem estava lá o presidente do
resort
ele é presidente de um grupo de sete
resort ele estava lá pra mim eu vi eu
disse minhas idéias
contei para ele tudo que eu tava
pensando ele sorriu acenou com a cabeça
fez suas considerações e depois voltei
para o meu trabalho porque eu sei que a
hora é confiado em mim para conduzir uma
reunião com o presidente do resort
assim como ela confiava em mim para
terminar de limpar a privada que estava
limpando a gente esquece de muita coisa
na nossa vida
se eu fizer a conta eu acho que esqueci
a maior parte dos dias da minha vida mas
eu nunca mais esquecer esse dia a gente
esquece o nome de tanta gente que passa
na vida mas eu nunca mais esqueci da
laura laura thomas e eu não sabia por
que aquilo tinha ficado tão forte pra
mim porque eu tinha representado tanto
na minha vida só foi descobrir um pouco
tempo depois
voltei para o brasil eu estava
procurando emprego aí eu comecei com
procurar aqui procura ali uma das vagas
que eu precisava que estava lá é
disponível precisava falar inglês levou
para lá vou eu até porque o nome da
empresa é um pouco difícil de dizer
great place to work aí eu cheguei na
empresa
o bom dia aqui o great place to work
eles falaram esse é fluente passou eu
estou eu beijo em 2011 estou lá no
brasil fez furor feliz e compensa para
quem não conhece conhece aquela empresa
que faz o ranking das melhores empresas
para trabalhar no brasil e no mundo
isso nos trouxe uma grande expertise do
que faz uma empresa ser considerada por
seus colaboradores a melhor empresa para
trabalhar e o que faz uma empresa não
ser considerada pelos mesmo uma boa
empresa
aí o interessante é que foi lá no
momento pensou antes que eu entendi
tecnicamente o que laura tinha oferecido
aquele dia e lá a gente resume com uma
única palavra o que ela nos deu
e essa palavra talvez seja o grande
segredo por trás das melhores empresas
para trabalhar
não é treino jogo de videogame pegorim
ping pong que você vai ser a melhor
empresa para trabalhar não é tem dos
melhores salários melhores benefícios na
pintando as paredes colorido
afinal de contas tem tanta empresa de
parede colorida cheia de pessoas insanas
o que transforma uma empresa é um
excelente lugar para trabalhar
é uma palavra simples e laura tinha me
dado foi pura e simplesmente um presente
presente no inglês gift no trabalho ou
ortiz nós inventamos uma palavra um
conceito que está por trás das melhores
empresas essa palavra disse ward é um
presente que muitas vezes você não
esperava receber um ambiente de trabalho
que para quem oferece não tem
investimento quase nenhum nem de tempo
nem de dinheiro mas para quem recebe um
valor que não tem tamanho
se hoje nós estamos falando de futuro eu
acredito convictamente que não haverá
futuro da empresa que não pensar em mesa
para empresas que não conseguirem ir
além
não existe empresa que vai além
o que existem são pessoas
que vão além é claro que nós temos que
ser melhores na nos finanças a na
inovação nos processos com os clientes
mas se a gente não conseguir ser melhor
com aqueles que vão da base para tudo
isso que são as pessoas
o futuro não existe e para esse futuro o
tamanho não é documento
pra você ter uma idéia interessante dado
das 500 maiores não melhore as maiores
empresas do mundo no ano de 2000 ou seja
17 anos
metade delas já não existe mais metade
delas já desapareceram e lá no google e
do facebook eu acho que foi quando
experimentei de fato na veia o que é
esse tal de sig seaworld tinha recém
chegado a empresa fazia 23 meses que
estava trabalhando eo período de
experiência né
eu estava também fazendo um curso de
teatro eu adoro teatro
essa coisa de subir a um palco e contar
uma história para alguém me encanta é
essa a essência do teatro e eu pra quem
já fez curso de teatro não sei se alguém
aqui já fez o término do curso consiste
em uma apresentação para sua família na
apresentação da peça teatral para a
família amigos geralmente fica uma longa
temporada de um dia apresentando às
vezes dois
o problema é que se um dia seria
justamente numa segunda feira
segunda feira é dia de trabalho e eu
fiquei num dilema será que eu perguntei
pro pessoal muito especial porque se eu
posso faltar esse dia e terminar o meu
curso de teatro ou desista de fazer o
curso de teatro e continuou a trabalhar
na empresa
foi aí que eu olhei mais uma vez para o
nome da empresa e lembrei que além de
saber pronunciá lo eu também sabia do
seu significado e fui conversar com a
gestora na época a panela e eu falei
assim pâmela
será que em tal segunda feira eu possa
não vir trabalhar porque eu tenho essa
apresentação do meu curso de teatro
e não esqueça como goleiro o fundo nos
meus olhos e falou assim cauê esse tipo
de coisa você não pergunta aqui esse
tipo de coisa
você avisa eu sei o quanto esse curso é
importante para você vá eu fui me
apresentei o curso foi o máximo
nós todos apresentamos
muito legal quando estávamos agradecendo
o público aquele a aplauso nessa família
que vai assistir todo mundo aplaudindo é
aquela coisa maravilhosa mas de repente
no fundo da platéia eu comecei a ouvir
um aplauso diferente
paul e cauê quando a luz se acende eu vi
que lá no fundo da platéia rui o rush
ozawa kielce o presidente do great place
to work junto com a panela e mais 10
pessoas e amigos do great place to work
que tinham de me assistir surpresa
naquela mesma noite o rui falou pra mim
é uma coisa ele falou assim cauê
esse negócio de teatro é importante para
você mesmo né
eu disse é que ele foi um dia eu vou
encontrar um palco pra você
aqui na nossa empresa e é por isso que
eu preciso dividir com vocês um e mail
que o rui mandou o pessoal da
organização do texas são paulo há umas
duas semanas atrás por esse meio vocês
podem perceber que estou aqui por engano
o
eu imaginava que ele poderia convencer
eu trouxe pessoas iriam puxar obrigada
obrigada a qual até ser a continuidade
em fim eo e falou isso né
onde eu vou encontrar então no fim das
contas esse palco eu estou aqui hoje
nada mais é do que o presente que o rui
havia me prometido no ano de 2011
quando eu entrei na água e pensou antes
isso depois depois disso eu acabei
virando diretor de educação corporativa
no bento pessoa e é isso que eu faço o
tempo todo e dou palestras treinamentos
viajar o brasil inteiro ouvindo
conhecendo e contando histórias de
líderes que fazem a diferença
eles me pagam para fazer isso não sou eu
que vou discutir
e como eu mais gosto de fazer conta a
história de eu terminar contando uma
essa história tem um nome e em nome
dessa história é você não tem idéia de
quem é andréia
viajei pelo interior de são paulo
curiosíssimo para saber quem era essa
tal diretora andréia
quando cheguei lá eu vi que não tinha
mesmo porque era uma pessoa
absolutamente fantástica uma pessoa
amável era um ser humano gift word não é
uma história pra gente que emocionou
demais
ela levantou a mão num determinado
momento da turma e falou assim que tal e
eu falei por favor andréia conta ela
falou quando ainda não era diretora
dessa empresa eu era gerente
eu fiquei muito emocionado um dia em que
meu diretor me ligou e falou assim
andréia eu preciso que você venha
imediatamente para minha sala e ela foi
quando chegou na sala da diretora abriu
a porta da sala e lá dentro da sala
estava ele e uma senhora ela olha melhor
para a senhora viu que a mãe dela ela
pensou em alguma desgraça tinha
acontecido na família
mais do que depressa se acalmar e falou
não tá tudo bem mas porque minha mãe
está aqui e ele explicou dizendo assim
andréia
não sei se você vai se recordar mas uma
das coisas que você já me disseram que
na sua carreira que eu nunca mais me
esqueci
foi justamente no dia em que eu te
promovido para gerente e no dia que eu
provei para gerente você falou assim
como eu gostaria
minha mãe estivesse vendo essa cena
porque eu sei que seria importante para
ela e hoje é um dia especial para você
ele falou porque você vai ser a diretora
da nossa empresa ea sua mãe está aqui
para assistir essa cena
ela terminou de contar essa história ela
se emocionou muito junto com o novo
todos nós inclusive até hoje eu mesma
zona quando eu lembro dessa cena é mais
bonito de tudo dessa história para
fechar é que a gente passa o tempo todo
nas empresas olhando para os lados pra
cima pra baixo querendo que o outro faça
algo a mais por você
a reflexão que fica é o que você está
fazendo a mais para sua organização do
seu gestor para sua equipe e seus
colegas porque o mais bonito do rift
work é a reciprocidade que existe nele
quando você recebe um gift work a sua
vontade máxima queria devolver a seguir
footwork vocês acham que andréia
devolve-se gift word para a empresa
você não tem idéia de quem é andréia que
tipo de diretora vocês acham que ela é
por essa organização que tipo de líder
que vocês acham que ela é pra essa
equipe e eu espero do fundo do coração
que esses últimos minutos que eu tive
com vocês possa ter sido a retribuição
do rift work que eu ganhei em 2011 da
panela do ruim dos meus amigos do great
place to work porque naquela
segunda-feira
de fato eu não fui trabalhar obrigado
ele é